With this movie, with Wonder Woman 1984,...
...we were already feeling like we were heading into some dark place as humanity...
...and where the world was going to,...
...and we wanted to reflect on that as human and show what we would like the world to be...
...and that was something that we tried to do in this movie.
And this movie is all about the truth...
...and being able to accept the truth as it is,...
...and it's all about hope and love.
Because of the way the movie was received, the first one, and the impact that it had,...
...we both knew that we got to up our game even more...
...and the bar was just super high.
So, the movie is just very ambitious.
The scope is huge.
As far as storytelling, we have four different storylines.
As far as the action goes, it was beyond...
...and Patty really made a point about wanting a minimal amount of CGI...
...and just really had to do so much of it by ourselves.
So, it was a lot.